madame monsieur bonsoir depuis l'aube
l'appareil est parqué en bout de piste
sur l'aéroport de téhéran la chaleur est
intense 42 degrés à l'ombre aujourd'hui
les passagers et l'équipage du boeing
d'air france détourné hier après midi de
sa route francfort paris sont toujours
les otages de trois mystérieux pirate de
l'air on ne sait rien des tractations
qu'il mènerait avec les autorités
iraniennes
sinon qu'ils ont demandé le plein de
carburant
le point de la situation avec philippe
rochot seul élément nouveau après 15
heures d'attentes sur l'aéroport de
téhéran trois femmes et un enfant malade
ont été autorisés à débarquer ces images
de la télévision iranienne nous ont
permis d'apercevoir l'un des pirates de
l'air portant un keffieh rouge un indice
de plus laissant supposer que le
commando est arabe et non pas persan
c'est d'ailleurs en langue arabe que se
déroulent les négociations avec les
autorités iraniennes
les pirates de l'air ont demandé le plat
en carburant mais les iraniens ont
refusé se contentant de fournir des
plateaux-repas laventure du 737 d'air
france pourrait bien se terminer ici une
aventure commencée entre francfort et
paris avec comme première étape
l'aéroport de genève où l'avion d'air
france sous la menace du commando fait
le plein dans l'espoir de gagner téhéran
mais devant le refus des autorités
iraniennes d'accueillir l'avion les
pirates heures de nos pilotes de mettre
le cap sur beyrouth à minuit les
autorités libanaises qui dans un premier
temps refusé l'atterrissage enlève en
catastrophe les camions et les bidons
ont disposé en travers de la piste et
acceptent de recevoir l'avion pour des
raisons humanitaires
walid joumblatt ministre des transports
exigent la libération des passagers en
échange d'un plein de carburant refus
des pirates qui font alors décollé
l'avion dans des conditions périlleuses
car la piste n'a été qu'en partie
dégagée direction larnaca sur l'île de
chypre à une demi heure de vol le boeing
reçoit alors le plein en carburant et un
steward daniele géant en profite pour
fausser compagnie aux pirates de l'air
c'est lui qui dira que personne n'a été
blessé dans l'appareil une heure plus
tard l'avion d'air france met enfin le
cap sur teheran les autorités iraniennes
comme les suisses les libanais où les
chypriotes ayant finalement autorisé la
pareille à se poser sur leur territoire